[Music]
all right everybody
we're back welcome or welcome back to
another
hotly anticipated edition of
roll on roll on
give me your bbc one introduction again
this is bbc radio 1.
there we go i like that can you do the
whole podcast in that accent
i cannot i'm good at that just that
otherwise it gets really weird
really quick if you're joining us on
youtube today
make sure you hit that subscribe button
if you haven't already
i'm told that that's effective in
building our subscriber base
yes also apparently there's a little
bell a little notification bell and if
you click that
you will be alerted every time we post a
new video
so and you can trick youtube into
sending you good stuff
exactly right yeah we're all here to
take control of the algorithm
are we not yes and i'm joined today of
course by my hype man bestie
journeyman journalist adventurer
environmentalist
author david goggins can't hurt me
co-author
adam scholnick how you doing man good
man how are you it's good
enthusiast swim run devotee
yeah back burner on the shelf with a new
baby
at home yeah new baby the new baby new
baby life is real man
you can't you can't you got your house
asleep
intermittent yeah if i get three
straight hours that's amazing
too bad uh the health benefits of of
intermittent sleeping don't match the
health benefits of intermittent fasting
right which i'm not doing more people
would have babies
if they have if what do you mean if
intermittent sleeping well you know how
interested everyone's like you gotta
intermittent fast but if it was
intermittent sleeping though they would
have that would be the craze
right this would be a way to they'd have
to be more
sleepy i thought you meant it would be
like you'd you wouldn't you'd wake up to
have the saxophone so
i kind of want to but i'm not going to
go to the trouble i thought that's what
you maybe that would happen too i don't
know
what we do here on the roll-on is
we invest a little bit of time in what
we call the big story
we try to throw a teachable moment or
two at you we do a little show and tell
we take
questions from listeners on our facebook
group if you would like your question
considered for us to contemplate and
talk about you can leave us a voicemail
424-235-4626
quickly becoming a new addition to the
format
is our fitness check-in yeah how's your
fitness check-in you went you swam
around the reef the other day i did
i i'll say two parts one is i'm that was
great i mean to be able to get back to
the reef and to see these
and it was it was 40-foot viz uh at
least it was really one of the more
beautiful days of the year
rays tons of fish that like new fish had
hatched so there was like baby fish
everywhere like explosions of baby fish
it was beautiful
um but you know to be honest like this
zone two stuff i feel like it's making
me
less fit like i feel i'm slower and more
breath out of breath but maybe it's the
sleep deprivation there's a couple
things with zone two first
is and i've said this before it's a it's
a long game
right so patience is key but the other
aspect of that is consistency it only
works when you're applying
it consistently day in and day out so if
you're if you're doing intermittent zone
two
yeah you're probably not reaping the
benefits and perhaps your
fitness has slipped okay um because
that's really how you make the gains is
when you're just like
showing up day in and day out day in and
day out and being patient like an hour a
day in zone two on a run
yeah it's gonna be different for for
everybody but if you're doing zone two
twice a week and not doing anything else
yeah your fitness is
good for me right now you've got a baby
yeah and you know everything has
a season yeah you know what i mean um
that's cool that you got out on the reef
uh what what i think a lot of people
don't realize is the best
i think the best time of year in los
angeles is september and october oh yeah
the weather's incredible
the water's warm oh yeah it's really it
was like 68 degree
water and and clear and then october
november is the best visibility on
on the california coast anyway i think
october is the best nut month
in almost every country like october and
may or like if you have
when we can ever travel again october
and may that's when you should travel
well it depends on where you're going
yeah right but october in los angeles is
very much a
an extended summer i mean the days are
shorter but the climate is super nice
so nice and temperate you're right um i
haven't swim around the reef in quite
some time but i did
go on a bike ride with my buddy mark
hancock the other day
mark is the guy that i did the catalina
uh swim run with oh you met him remember
he's greg renfrow's husband greg's uh a
past
podcast guest she's the founder and ceo
of beauty counter and mark is
super fit like an incredible athlete
and i love doing some training with him
and when we were preparing for the
catalina race
i took him down to do that swim and then
we were running all over the bluffs
because that's the one place
in our kind of general region where you
can approximate
some kind of authentic swim run
experience because it's hilly like most
of the beaches around here everything's
too flat
right but that's one place where you can
climb those trails
and get some elevation and stuff like
that but he
like was sort of freaking out when we
went around the reef
at at is that what do you call that it's
it's on the way to little doom
like a lot of people call it big doom
and then that cove that beach there is
big doom and little doom is on the other
side of the smaller point
it's very exposed there's a lot of seals
there's a lot of marine life
sea lions and sea lions and there's
there's uh
the general consensus is this is a shark
feeding ground
yes right and so and it's true i've done
that swim a ton of times i've done it
with you
uh it is a little bit freaky and
treacherous when you're out there
because you
definitely have a sense that you are
exposed and in the wild yes
although i've never seen anything that
scared me you you're on high alert for
sure
and mark since that experience has told
some friends
that he swam around the big doom point
yeah
and he told me that like all his friends
are like i can't believe you did that
like
you're like risking your life like
that's super sketchy to do that and we
do
how many times have you done it i mean i
moved out there to do it like five times
a week i did
you know like i've got a buddy who's
still out there like four or five times
a week
and when he's not working he's in
productivity sharks ever
we've never seen uh we've seen a blue
shark we've seen mola mola there was a
turtle sighting not too long
ago you know i think that so the in
terms of shark attacks
we see seals uh sea lions that have been
washed up with big bites out of them i
have a friend who surfs
a big doom sometimes and he said he
literally was surfing when he saw a
great white eating a
whale calf oh my god um and he just kept
surfing and he's like well he's got food
so it's all good
um luckily one time we we finished our
swim and we came out
on the staircase and over overlooking
the blocks it was a beautiful day we
were just basking in
you know in raw nature and thinking wow
what a wonderful day isn't it beautiful
out there it was
clear and the blue water is glittering
with sunlight and all of a sudden we see
a white shark just
breach and flop down right where we'd
been
and we just looked at each other and
said nothing and just moved along
wow um but no we've never seen a white
a white shark i think we will at some
point i mean you know the odds are
eventually
might um but uh i'm not
you know i used to be scared about it i
used to sometimes when i'm out there
alone you might still feel it
um like like the darkness
approaching it's in your brain the
water's quite clear out there but on
murky days that's where it gets scary
because you can't
see you know and there's a sense of
powerless the murky days are
when you get scared but um and there's
powerless you are in the food chain but
most of the
the attacks i mean i look at any time
there's an attack first of all we don't
really have them too
i mean i i can't remember last time i
was publicized in our area
and the ones that were were kayak
fishermen and
they got nobody died uh there was a guy
who got bit
in manhattan beach by a juvenile white
shark not too long ago an open water
swimmer
and that was because he'd been uh going
after the bait
of the pier fisherman so it's it tends
to be
you know the the free divers that get
hit or the open water swimmers and get
hit
it can be bad like around here anyway it
can be bad luck but often it's it's
related to fishing
and we're not doing that and yeah we're
around their
their food it's true um they are
ping pinging off those buoys and those
buoys have like a radio
kind of receptor and and any white
sharks that have been tagged
do ping those buoys and so they're there
are side
there they do hear if if it comes within
a quarter mile or a half mile the buoy
they they ping
so yes it happens wow um but you know
it's funny sunset
point in like in the bay is
like within a mile of sunset point there
is a shark nursery a white shark nursery
that's known
so that's actually swimming temescal
where i've been swimming lately
for swim run training is i think is much
more
in terms of white sharks we've seen one
breach there too wow
there's a lot more people in the water
and there's more people in the water
sure
i think you know we're all scared
because of
nobody wants to die that way but uh and
because of jaws and all that
but in reality i think it's you know you
have better chance of getting struck by
lightning
than well we kill a hundred million
sharks a year yeah
a hundred million kill and there are
five people who die by shark attacks
every year
yeah they're just crazy do you know uh
michael muller
yeah so i had him on the podcast uh i
have his book
he was amazing yeah it's incredible he
gave me a copy of that book he did the
podcast
recently that's going to go up in a
couple weeks but we spent
the graviment of that conversation
talking about his
adventures photographing sharks and and
swimming out of the cage with sharks
yeah that has really reframed how i
think about
these creatures yes um it's an amazing
podcast i can't wait to share it
i can't wait to listen i think he posted
on his uh instagram
not too long ago maybe it was like a
year ago about like
if people knew how close sharks really
came to them in the water even just
around here
like nobody would be swimming in the
ocean some sort of like hint like that
but
he's not afraid of him i feel the same
way i feel like we might see one
the thing to do if you're out in deeper
water and you see one is to group
up like in a knot and everyone face
outward and
to kind of make you like you know make
yourself bigger and
um not splash around or or you know as
hard as that might well the other thing
he said
was that you s you should swim towards
them yeah right
it goes against every instinct that
you're gonna have
yeah but because they are the apex
predator
or the top of the food chain they're not
used to that
so in their brain they're thinking oh
this is a predator and they will
turn off now that's all this said there
are pl
parts of the world where shark attacks
are more common north carolina
florida australia i'm even hawaii i'm
not minimizing
the fear of sharks or mars vineyard yeah
i'm like exactly i'm not like saying i'm
this big brave guy but
where we are just the history of it is
it's it's uh
it's pretty far down what could go wrong
famous last words yeah
but hey if it happens no i i think that
our plan
we do talk about it if we see a shark
out here what to do
and we always say calm try to enjoy it
and then swim in as soon as you can
uh-huh that that's that'll all go out
the window the moment that happens i
would suspect
i would think so um all right we're
still on the fitness check-in
are we not i think so i gotta get into
vegan gains
i gotta yeah i gotta check in on the
swole update yeah so
the strength training is ongoing as i
mentioned
the last time we got together i've been
going to this gym where they
set stuff up outside and i wear a mask
and you know we social distance and
there's only a couple people there but
i've been
really consistent with it and it's been
fun like my body has definitely
changed like i'm back to i was never
like a
gym rat and i've never been that strong
in the gym i've never been somebody who
threw big weights around or anything
like that even when i was swimming and
we were doing heavy weights three times
a week
i was like okay you know i was never
like yeah
like way back then but my goal was to be
able to lift
the kind of weight that i could lift in
college when i was swim training
at stanford and i thought it would take
me at least until november to get there
but i'm already there which is great
and i did it by just like literally like
the first couple weeks i would only go
for like 20 minutes
than 30 minutes and now i'm up to like
an hour and a half
and and i'm feeling like different in my
body like i have more
control and i definitely have bulked up
a little bit
not too much but it's interesting
and unfamiliar in contrast to
when you're really focused on endurance
and you're trying to get as lean as
possible and it's all about power to
weight like
letting go of that and trying something
different
has been cool and like i said at the
outset of the podcast like everything
has a season right so
right now like this is the season that
i'm focused on
and it's cool you know i'm somebody who
was really fit in college
and then i got fat and then i lost a
bunch of weight and then i got
fit and then i got crazy skinny like in
2011 when i did
ultraman that year i was like down to
158 like i was
i was like too lean um and
now to be able to kind of bulk up a
little bit
and get strong has been a cool
experience for a variety of reasons not
the least of which is
uh to say as somebody who's been vegan
for
13 coming on 14 years at this point like
i can still
put on mass and i can still make gains
in the gym without any animal products
in my diet
and i think it speaks to this counter
argument that you hear a lot
from the peanut gallery when an athlete
goes plant-based and then performs well
the
the the kind of retort that you hear is
well he he
he or she made all their gains when they
were eating animal products and they're
just
riding on the coattails of that but in
truth
i've had so many permutations in my
fitness journey
and i've been vegan for so long to go
from like
really skinny where my arms were like
toothpicks and i could swim all day but
not with much power
to now having you know some some heft on
me
and um be able to kind of pack that back
on
has been cool so part of the you know in
terms of like the storytelling aspect of
it like
hey you know at 54 i can get strong
again
after being vegan for this long and
being at my age and that feels good so
more amazing more to be revealed not
that like
i'm not holding myself out as some kind
of you know like you know this is a
process
like i'm not like insanely fit or
anything like that i'm just trying
something different and new
i think it's great i mean i think
there's a lot to be said for
weights especially to water sports i
mean i don't know about um
endurance sports as much you would know
more than me but i would imagine like
getting
having strength can only help you right
right but at
some point it becomes diminishing
returns depending upon
what you're trying to do like when i got
crazy skinny
like i said i could i could open water
swim for hours
and not get tired and you don't build up
any lactic acid because your
muscles are so reduced like now if i was
to go out and swim
i'm strong and i'm sure i'd be able to
you know have more
more uh force in each pull
but i'm not going to be able to do a 10
kilometer swim
the way that i could when i was training
in a different way so there's just
trade-offs with that
it's always trade-offs yeah yeah i i
think uh well that's cool it's a good
journey
that's one thing i've been missing since
uh
covid is i used to go to this um
high-intensity
interval training gym in santa monica
circuit works
and really it was an integral part of
what we were doing my wife and i
was like i was doing that i was swimming
and i was running
uh more and more off the treadmill but
like i'd had the foot problems and the
treadmills where i was able to get back
on it in these
in these intervals and uh i haven't had
that so i started doing more distance
running which got my running a lot
better and got my swim runs better
and now i'm coming back to this i'm like
wow i really missed the
the strength because i have lost weight
and strength and
uh so i might start to do some of that
in a park with one of those trainers in
like
a socially distant way he's like
starting to meet people
in a park so i might be one of those
guys on in a park yeah you see those
guys you see them right
now i'll be a yoga mat they they
they like you know pop the hatching on
the back of their car and they're it's
just filled with fitness equipment yeah
that's him
i'm the guy that comes in and please
don't watch
because i'm not i'm not i'm not an
attractive runner
well there used to be i don't know
what's going on now but close to where
you live
uh at the santa monica stairs yeah right
so at the top of the stairs there's a
little grassy area and there would
always be those guys there like running
fitness classes
right close the stairs
little median strip people would like
sunbathe at the median they would like
right picnics
i'm like so that's still going on oh
you've been buying in a while yeah yeah
every every day um all right shifting
gears so
i don't know about you but the social
dilemma documentary hasn't left me
like it kind of lives in my unconscious
mind
and it has changed altered my
relationship with with social media i've
kind of really pulled back
and one of the things i've been thinking
about and this is
all about me like i've been thinking
about
turning off the comments on youtube okay
in part because of that documentary
but also because i found myself unable
to stop
checking them really and i kind of
scroll through them and
look a lot of there's a lot of people
there who say nice things or offer
constructive
criticism or feedback and i'm all about
that that's totally fine
but it's also like a complete [ __ ] show
yeah and i question like alright what is
the purpose
of these comment sections if it's to
create a place for healthy debate and
conversation
that's one thing but if it becomes a
breeding ground
for bot manipulation and all kinds of
half-baked strange theories or
just ad hominem attacks on on either the
guest or myself what what are we doing
here
you know what i mean well isn't it i
thought what if i turn these off does
that then create the argument like oh he
doesn't want to hear feedback
or you know i don't i don't know but i
thought as an experiment i might try to
turn them off and see what happens
why not i mean is anything productive
coming out of these
i learned long ago don't read the
comments i mean when you when you write
stories for these
publications that have the big uh you
know
and you have you have that you have a
huge subscriber base and listenership
and
and so you're gonna get that same kind
of blowback and
and often it becomes people personal
gripes or
uh or you know a take on
your story that you know they didn't
jive with it's it's almost
always negative because it's the same
thing it's not about social connection
as you'd want it to be a place for a
forum for constructive criticism and
connection and discussion but really
it's about engagement and engagement can
cut negative
more often than positive right because
the way the internet
works like yeah you know even even
when you text your friend if you text
them kind of something it can be
misperceived
so imagine that on a comment section
when they're not your friends and
you know like who knows i'm sure they
know who these people are you don't know
if they're real people
right um and and really it's just about
my relationship to it like i just need
to
not look at that because i don't want to
be influenced one way or the other i
want to be able to speak freely and
share my heart and not be thinking if i
say that somebody's going to comment
this
like it lives in my it you know it lives
in my awareness and i don't like that
but
no i think what i'm going to do is just
stop reading them
and try that but like it's like that
addictive thing like i have to
like i want to gauge the temperature of
how this particular conversation lands
with people yeah so then i find myself
checking it and then i'm like why did
especially like at night like terrible
idea oh my god
right before bed i think well if i'm
creating like by virtue of publishing a
video and putting it on youtube
and allowing that comment section to be
open am i
participating or contributing to
uh some kind of manipulation that occurs
there by
you know forces that don't have people's
best interests at heart
yeah i mean i think i think the idea of
youtube is the force
has only one interest at heart and
that's continued engagement right so
it's not like it's some
that's the thing about social dilemma
it's not like even even the people that
we
might say how dare they create these
things and let them run rampant and have
no
no responsibility over them and all
they're just cashing in
really they didn't mean to create this
this problem
they were looking at the positives like
you were saying like social discussion
social connection that's what their goal
was you know and make money of course
and and it just turns out engagement
trumps everything and so
um that's the deal i mean i think you
know you don't have that problem with
your twitter mentions where where
people are negative like that i mean a
little bit but it's easy
it's it's not as much yeah because i
think you've
in a way just who you are and the stuff
you cover
and the guests you have on and the
people that listen it's a nurturing
place like you created actually one of
the more nurturing communities
there's plenty of people who have but
probably youtube but the point is is the
youtube
videos that are posting are going to
other people that aren't the listener
based on the
broadcast they're finding you yeah yeah
and so i think and they're getting
served here
right it's a different thing because
yeah they're getting served up and they
don't have any background or familiarity
with who i am and what i do
so it's coming at them completely
sideways and out of the blue and so
they're like who's this
idiot that's fine
whatever all right you know i guess what
i'm gonna do is just
commit to not looking at it you commit
to not reading the comments
i mean it's one thing in the facebook
group which you might want to check in
that's different because that's a that's
a you know curator yeah it's curated
that community is coming there for a
reason so it's different yeah i agree
um all right enough of that cool the
main thing that i want to talk about
today
kind of the um big story aspect of
this podcast episode is to talk about
this new documentary called
kiss the ground it's on netflix i'm sure
many of you have seen it
at this point it just premiered the
other day it's directed by joshua tickle
and rebecca harold tickle who are
environmental
filmmakers it's narrated by woody
harrelson woody
what's not to love about woody he's the
best woody tom brady just great
come on um yeah there's a lot of
celebrity cameos in this jason mraz and
we got gisele and my boy tom brady
love tom brady wait do you know him no
he follows me on instagram though
yeah he's last time he's all about
lifestyle no no i haven't healthy
um of course he's gotta be in this chair
one day gotta make that happen yeah we
gotta get anybody knows tom brady yeah
let's make that happen in any event he
looks great on there tom
there's a lot of good about this movie
um and it essentially posits that we can
not only stave off climate change
but we can actually significantly draw
down carbon
by way of soil regeneration
and it's kind of a meditation on the
existential crisis
that we face and it's very hopeful in
the solution
that it offers which is this pivot from
these this sort of uh cafo
slash industrialized farming
system that we've created and pivoting
to a regenerative
way of relating to the land right
because it's sustainable
they point out that we're having a huge
soil erosion problem where
um every two thirds of the world is
desertified and this is increasing
and it's and it all started with
human-based
agriculture and they link it to all
these failed civilizations and they
linked certification to that
and the idea being that you can be
regenerative
regenerative instead of extractive and
still and still
and actually help farmers it actually
will be a boon to farmers so
right um that's a big piece of it i mean
god bless that guy whose name i forget
who
spends all his time traveling around
meeting with farmers right
yeah yeah explaining to them yeah
exactly like what an amazing
human that he's you know not only
evangelizing
um how important this is but
connecting with these farmers one-on-one
to actually show them that if they do
this
um they can be successful and more
profitable and that farmer that the
example of the farmer was
right um who is he's out in the midwest
and
he had his entire he was doing
oh tilling the idea is you know
chill is a right so tilling is is is
what creates the erosion problem and the
idea is
this guy had was doing that going by the
book
by but 95 of the farmers do because only
five percent are regenerative
and so he was doing that and he had his
crops three years in a row wiped out by
hail storm hailstorm and then drought
and he was on the brink of bankruptcy
and he
used that suffering that that crucible
to completely reinvent
how he was growing food and he became
kind of the poster child of regenerative
agriculture in his area and and what he
his
anecdotal stuff i mean what he's what he
is showing on the
what you can see plainly on camera and
everything he's saying
it is it is cool yeah it's it it is it's
super cool and i think the movie does a
great job of
explaining um this idea of drawdown
and how carbon works this this concept
of carbon sequestration
and how important soil and soil
regeneration
is in that equation right they take the
soil regeneration
and they link it to climate change and
carbon sequestration which is
uh real quick is like plants basically
are carbon stores and they can store it
in their roots which then puts it into
the soil so
it takes the co2 out of the atmosphere
produces oxygen and so if you
if you uh cover your land if you have
cover crops all the time you never till
um you can re retain water better retain
the soil better and sequester carbon
and so this it's they they position it
as not just a good thing for soil
and farmers and food but a good thing
for
uh climate change so much of the climate
change
discussion revolves around reducing our
emissions
but that's only a small fraction of the
solution because
we have all this carbon in our
atmosphere and unless we figure out a
way to
draw it down just reducing the amount
that we're contributing to it
actually isn't solving the problem right
right it's like reducing how much you're
putting on your credit card when you're
100 000 in credit card debt
right like i'm going to charge less but
i'm not paying any of it down
right you know is is the idea and i
think the movie also did a really good
job
of of kind of casing the history of how
we got to this point through the dust
bowl and what happened after that and
then the introduction of
chemical fertilizers and in particular
glyphosate and the impact that that has
had
on the farming community and our food
systems at large which is a subject that
i've gone into in depth many times with
zac bush probably um most in depth in
our first episode which was episode 353
if you haven't listened to that if you
watch the movie and you haven't listened
to that podcast
i think you'll find that quite
illuminating and instructive
so lots to love about this the
importance of no-till
uh the role of regenerating soil in this
climate equation
and and and some really good education
on this existential threat that that we
face that we really are at a turning
point and the stakes
are very high and what happens if we
don't start living in the solution right
the impact of
you know this increasingly uh dire
climate change on not just the
environment at large but on human beings
like 1 billion refugees by 2050. like
you know it's
it's already starting and this is very
real and
transitioning farms to regenerative
principles
is like this huge and great thing and
the idea that
that they're taking soil education
mainstream and packaging it
in a very entertaining documentary i
think is something to be celebrated
totally and there's even an amoeba sex
scene where they play like sex
sensual music and you see like little
amoebas like getting together
all right to uh what was the me what was
the song they used for that like
sexual healing yeah it was like
essentially like it was like
they couldn't get the rights i also
liked
the case study of the los plateau in
china and how they restored
um you know this once amazing part of
china that had become desertified and
now it's thriving which is really cool
and that was the example of like this
huge empire that had fallen because they
they cultivated that place and then
it's completely deserted right um i also
like that it's sort of a
rrp roundup yeah pun intended
yes we got rylan engelhardt who's a
producer on the film uh who's been on
the podcast and he
and his family are the ones behind the
cafe gratitude chain
of restaurants which is also in um which
is in the movie as well yeah paul hawkin
of course
um who we're going to get into in a
little bit more in depth
is really kind of the anchor to this
whole movie um his book drawdown which i
have right here which i want to talk
about a little bit more and and you know
long time listeners will
will remember him from the live event
that we did in los angeles talking about
all these issues and then david broner
also who's
just i love david he's the best yeah
he's amazing talk about a good twitter
follow
oh my god i know and uh and and a lot of
the philosophy and kind of backbone of
what's discussed in this movie really
does echo
the work of zach busch he's doing
something similar with farmer's
footprint which is his non-profit
and i should mention that rylan you know
in addition to being producer on the
film
kiss the ground is is his non-profit
that is behind the production of this
movie okay
as well um it also bears resemblance to
the biggest little farm documentary did
you see that no yeah
yeah no i didn't see it but they they
have a stand at the farmers market on
wednesday in santa monica
every day like the people behind that
right yeah molly
and john who were on the podcast as well
um and you know having visited that farm
i can attest to you know what it's like
to put your hands and your feet in soil
that has been
regenerated to such an extent and the
contrast that exists because their farm
um butts up against a similar
conventionally farmed plot that
that is you know kind of what you see
with that guy you know
in in the movie where he's like this is
my land and this is the next door
neighbor's farm and you could see the
desertification in the soil
um the ability of this soil to like hold
the water
and become more resilient in terms of
drought like there's there's so much
um that's amazing about this process of
regenerating the soil and to celebrate
so overall like
i love the movie for that um and i
should say
um i do you know i have a couple issues
with the movie that i want to get into
in a second but before i
before i do that um you know when i when
i did the podcast with the chesters the
biggest little farm people like i took
some heat
from the vegan community because
this farm like the farms portrayed in
kiss the ground
they're they use animals like yeah
they're ranchers
there's animal husbandry going on and
some of those animals are sold
to slaughter and as i said
in that podcast and in kind of response
to the criticism that i got like my
intention in hosting them on the podcast
was to celebrate this beautiful movie
that they made but also to focus on
soil you know and and how important it
is that
we you know get into this idea of
drawing down carbon by regenerating our
soil
um you know as a as an as a you know
something that's set aside from the
ethics of
animal husbandry in general and it was
also an attempt at
intellectual honesty you know i think as
as somebody who's vegan plant-based
there's an idea
in the vegan community that you're
living a harm-free life
and i think that that's a it's a it's a
fallacy and it's not intellectually
honest
it's an aspiration to live more gently
on the planet
um but if you're eating an avocado as
john chester said in our podcast like
he has to go through extraordinary
lengths to keep the gophers from eating
right the avocados right and initially
before he reached some kind of balance
with his ecosystem
he would have to kill gophers in order
to protect the avocado trees so there's
harm that's the result of all of the
choices that we make
it's just a calibration
of your relationship to that harm so in
the case of the gophers and the avocado
trees that harm
is more indirect like you're not
involved in the slaughter of an animal
to eat that food
but the idea that it exists outside of
any harm whatsoever
i think is something that which is not
true and i think it's important
to be like it's not a credit to the
plant-based or vegan movement to not be
intellectually honest about these things
we are aspiring to live more gently and
that's something that i
believe in and try to do but i'm not
under any illusion that the choices that
i make
don't have deleterious implications down
the line i'm just trying to be
in a place where those are as reduced as
i possibly can make them that's a great
point and um
also i think we need to resist this idea
of being in
silos with like minds and that if we
if we are only with this live gently
crowd
that our life can be better and and you
know we're making an impact and
and and all the rest because look our
problems are so
deep and and varied that we do need to
build the bridges to other people doing
work that can be beneficial and positive
right
and who are the people that we're
slinging arrows at right now let's let's
try to celebrate the wins and i think
the move
from you know conventional farming to
regenerative farming is of course
a step in the right direction so i'm not
in the business of trying to vilify
any farmers who are trying to make that
switch i want to i want to
be somebody who can champion that move
now
like i would like to believe that if i
was john chester and running that farm
that i would
not make the choice to sell my pigs to
slaughter
but i'm also not him and i don't
understand the economics of what's
required to
you know maintain the financial
well-being of such an enterprise
so i don't want to stand in judgment of
that um
and these issues are are are complex and
and
and complicated so i think we need to
focus on the big problems that we're
trying to solve well also if you're not
killing
then the pigs are are actually
performing a service on your land
to uh i think i mean yeah and this is
this is kind of what we're going to get
into
in a little bit yeah which is really you
know the role
of these ruminants i mean pigs aren't
ruminants but
you know the role of the ruminants on
the land and
um the the extent to which
that's necessary in this regenerative
process
and i think my issue with the movie and
again you know
everybody should see this movie and i
love ryland and i think what these guys
are doing are fantastic and i want to
celebrate that but i think there's a
couple things that
are overlooked and and this idea that
regenerative ag is this
panacea that is a simple solution
thesis for solving our climate crisis is
not exactly correct this is much more
nuanced
and complex and i don't know whether
there's a
a disingenuity to this or a desire to
avoid audience division
but basically the movie celebrates this
guy alan savory
um in a kind of pollyanna way and and
for those
that don't know alan savory did this
he's this
african rancher he did this ted talk
that has millions and millions of views
it's very compelling
and his basic thesis is that grazing
reverses desertification
and climate change but what it fails to
really
tackle is that grazing is also the major
driver of deforestation and
topsoil loss globally there really isn't
any credible peer-reviewed science to
support
savory's thesis and it's also not clear
on the role or the advantages that these
ruminants have
on the regenerative process and there's
a school of thought
that's supported by science that that
that that idea that ruminants are
absolutely necessary to this is is a
little overblown
um he's uh he's certainly improves the
soil a white rancher
from zimbabwe right correct yeah um
certainly these regenerative farms are
improving the soil
but actually forests do it better
than these farms and none of this
works unless global meat demand
is significantly reduced drastically
reduced some say up to 75
percent anybody who's wanting to shift
to holistic grazing
and keep producing meat at today's
volume at current demands
is kind of indirectly advocating for the
tearing down of forests
in order to make room because there just
isn't enough room
to do all of this and this is a long way
of saying that there's a bit of
green washing in this documentary
and this is this is a a subject that my
buddy
simon hill from the plant proof podcast
went into
into detail with this guy nicholas
carter who's an environmental
scientist guy's amazing i think you know
i i think i might reach out to him
to get him on the podcast because he's
great they did a whole
podcast on this subject matter that i
would encourage everybody
to check out uh carter's uh like i said
an environmental researcher
he's focused on the scientific links
between agriculture and planetary health
he's got a website that's got tons of
resources on it called plantbasedata.org
that you should check out
there's also another guy called dr
jonathan foley he goes by
at global eco guy on twitter who's a
climate and environmental scientist
who's been
speaking about this issue specifically
um recently
and the problem is that there's this
idea
that's kind of interliniated throughout
the movie kind of inferred not quite
stated expressly that cows are the
solution to the problem
because there's a solution to the
climate crisis yeah it's just it's just
not it's a positive truth it could be a
positive carbon
it could be carbon positive to have more
cows grazing
not in feed lots not in cafes but
grazing
over land right and and i think that
that's
a fallacy right now 40 40 to 50
of all land is used for agriculture most
of that is for animal agriculture for
livestock and for grazing
only five to ten percent of land is used
for human crops
and land is only crops meaning that a
lot of that like
feed right yeah it's like it's used for
feed right corn corn and soy and we're
deforesting
we're clearing that land to grow that
feed so
the forests are what we should really be
focusing on the forest and the wetlands
which are much more effective at
sequestration than grasslands
it also should be pointed out that that
this whole thesis
is about ruminants but chickens and pigs
are not ruminant so like what are we
doing about
the chickens and the pigs are they
grazing
wildly like i'm not sure how that plays
into
this whole equation as well well yeah so
i think that
my flyover on this is uh
is is like one of the problems is is
that there
yes there's this need to preserve
topsoil farming regeneratively
is a good thing um but it is
sensationalistic like and and it's high
on
kind of feel on like emotion but very
low on specifics as to the problems
being solved by anybody
in their movie and the greater problem
which is there's x number of cows that
are contributing
x amount of methane and here's the
desertification
because if the argument is all these
areas around the world have been
desertified
if we if we use this philosophy
and instead of doing cafos ship cows
in all these different parts of the
world and create regenerative
ranches then we can replace that meat
that is produced which clearly is not
possible
um that would be one thing but they
don't really get into any of that at all
so the specifics are so low
that you don't ever get a sense of the
problem let alone the solution
and um so i think that's the problem and
i i don't know if it's
greenwashing because these aren't you
know big companies trying to
pretend they're environmental or or just
sometimes you see this where you you
you you're trying to claim too much
and and the claim is is greater than the
proof you've got and i think that's
probably what's happening um you never
get a sense
of of of the problem in any real way
you just get fed kind of like high level
like emotional strings that are getting
plucked
um but they don't and that's good to the
extent that it's getting people
excited and active about solutions so
again like i want to be very careful
like i'm not
i'm not against this movie i think you
know regenerative
you know regenerating the soil is
something we should all be
excited about but let's be
intellectually honest about it
regenerative raised cows live longer
than kfo cows so they're going to use
more resources
they're going to consume more they're
going to require much more land like
when you see the
the marker grad ranch in half moon bay
in the movie
it's massive right but
the cattle is nominal like i don't know
how many heads of cattle they have on
that ranch but it didn't seem like that
many
for such a massive plot of land so this
is what we're talking about
most of the um grazed grass-fed cattle
still those farmers still feed them feed
for the last hundred days to like fatten
them up but not all of them but some of
them do
also when they're eating grass they're
eating a more fibrous diet and that
means they're producing more methane
four times as much methane
and you just the truth is you can't feed
the world this way with current meat
demand
um but meanwhile we've cut down 45 of
all the trees
like we should be talking also about
reforestation so
what you eat and how much you eat is
actually more impactful
than than where it comes from because
the other argument is like well
if you're vegan or vegetarian you're
eating these monocropped
foods the soy and the grains and the
things like that
or soy that's imported from somewhere
else but actually there's
studies that have run the math on this
this and
it basically indicates that imported soy
is still less problematic than
the grass-fed beef that's grown like
down the road from you
less problematic yeah environmentally
environmentally
so there isn't enough land if we want to
continue to eat animal products
at the level that we do today the
livestock sector is going to continue to
be very significant in terms of the
greenhouse gas
emissions that that are emitted my big
alarm bell went off in terms of just
like
glossing over something in the film was
uh the claim of biodiversity
because the idea is that monocrop farms
are not diverse but
uh but regenerative farms are very
biodiverse there's multiple crops
there's
there's animals there's insects and and
bacteria and mycorrhizal fungi and
everything happening in the soil
which is positive which is true but
that's not when i think of biodiversity
that's i don't think of human engineered
biodiversity i think of actual
biodiversity like
like in a kelp forest underwater or in a
rain forest
in in or a cloud forest or in even in
the desert because they kind of vilify
deserts and then they show joshua tree
which is actually an intact ecosystem
so you know like there right now the un
is calling for um 30 by 30. it's a
campaign called 30 by 30
which is 30 of all land in all oceans
preserved preserved completely from
from human activity by 2030.
that's what it's going to take to help
combat the effects of climate change
and they want to go to 50 by 50 by 2050.
so it's this idea that the less we
interact
with a specific area actually the better
off
earth is and so it's getting to your
point in that
you know there's there's a very
human-centric element to this as if we
can solve a problem that we've already
caused
and i rebel against that because uh
first of all
we're when we stop hunting for a certain
thing or stop growing a certain thing or
stop
monkeying with a certain forest it pops
back that's just how nature
is that's the idea with no till when you
stop tilling
your farm becomes just by nature your
soil becomes
uh more biodiverse in the soil but
that's not to me
what biodiversity really means that's
not what the un is calling biodiversity
that's that is more biodiverse than a
monocrop
desertifying farm but it's not
biodiversity
writ large and and so that's that that
yeah that's the kind of stuff savory
would probably say
that that he's giving the land a head
start
by trying to you know create that
biodiversity by planting the cover crops
and all the different kinds of grasses
like he's trying to create an
environment where that
can be more like what it would be like
if we were leaving it alone
yet also be a place that we could use to
harvest food to feed humans
right but you could also accomplish
there's people trying to rewild buffalo
because
like instead of using cows you could try
to rewild wolves and buffalo and there
are people doing that you know wolves
have been rewilded in yellowstone and
other places
and buffalo there are people trying to
get buffalo rewilded that that can go
from canada to mexico
again through this area that used to be
full of bison
and and uh that the bison were wiped out
as a part of a campaign
to not only trap and get the fur but
also to
destroy indigenous cultures and and
commit genocide
uh post-civil war and the western
expansion pre-amp post i would guess
and and so you could also rewild you
know there's other
solutions that can still use some of the
same thing they're talking about grazing
big animals over large part pieces of
land
planting the right grasses because it
also matters what you're planting
if you're if you're if you're managing a
big farm
you're not necessarily planting native
grasses you're planting grasses that are
going to benefit free
for your you know animal or for your
crop right
so not everything is created equal not
every plant is this
like an indigenous grass is is is what
you need in a certain area
not if you're trying to create real
biodiversity not just a grass that can
be eaten by your cow
now i'm i'm i'm picking i'm being i'm
being picky
but that's that's the problem i had this
claim of biodiversity because it's not
explained that well
in the film yeah back to paul hawkin who
again
is like an anchor in here he's the guy
who's been boots on the ground
studying this stuff for a very long time
um
his book drawdown which everybody should
get i have a copy here which basically
phenomenal yeah chronicles uh the most
comprehensive plan ever proposed to
reverse global warming
not not reduce it reverse it right and
so
it goes kind of subject by subject
through all these different
methodologies modalities
to draw down carbon number four
out of all of them is a plant-rich diet
and the movie
does do a section on this yeah and
that's where you see ryland and you see
david broner like these guys are vegans
yeah
um but they they don't really make the
point
which i wish they would have made which
is that if we really want to be in the
solution here we have to move towards
not just a plant-rich diet like
ultimately a plant-based diet or a
mostly plant-based diet we have to
reduce
our reliance on meat that's a huge part
of this
plant-rich diet and drawdown if we can
make that
pivot that would be responsible for 66
gigatons
of carbon as pointed out in the book
regenerative ag is number 11 at 23
gigaton so this is
more important by a factor of three
in terms of what's going to move the
needle the most
number five is tropical forest which
goes back to reforestation at 61
gigatons
so i think soil regeneration is key and
crucial and beautiful
and amazing and if every conventional
farmer made this pivot we would live in
a better world than we do today
yes but it is a piece in a larger puzzle
if we really want to solve this problem
another good thing about the movie is
they did spend time on reducing food
waste yeah which is huge which is
amazing and that's something that eludes
kind of us
you don't talk very much about it yeah
paul and i talked about it
in our live event and it's number three
in drawdown
food waste is the is is like such a huge
problem and to the extent that we can
create systems to alleviate this
because i think we're just relying on us
like not throwing away our scraps like
it's never gonna work
but no that case study in san francisco
where there's businesses that
incentivize people to make sure that
that food ends up
in a compostable bin and that bin goes
to a certain place where they can
process this and create compost i think
is amazing it's not businesses it's the
government right the government makes
my my sister lives in the bay area and
they have it in all it's it's kind of
grown from san francisco across the bay
area and you get fined
for putting right so makes that point
yeah like
you you you don't you you only pe you
pay when you screw up right yeah you got
how it works
yes so you pay a fine if your
compostable
uh food waste ends up in the trash or in
the
recycle bin right and so you and you get
up you get
you get money back you pay less uh if
you don't have that much
in your uh black uh trash bin and the
trash bins are tiny
they're really slender things right
they're like you it's like when you go
to your thousands
you go to europe you go to europe and
the trash bins are all tiny yes you know
that
yeah and you're like how do you live
this way yeah and it just makes you
realize how in america we're such a
refuse
oriented culture we are just bloated i
know bloated
greedy yeah [ __ ] you're in a like an
apartment
in you know some city in europe and the
trash can is literally like you know
two feet tall by one foot or something
like that you're like
for a family i throw more away in one
day i know it's
terrible i know hey listen i'm the guy
putting diapers in a
in a bin right now right yeah
you're not recycling your diapers uh
without regenerative recycling
regenerative diapers
actually when i leave here i'm going to
be uh doing a massive
diaper clean and hang out like i've got
this clothes line it stretches across
san vicente
it's just my child's diapers awesome
there's a bunch of studies uh on all the
stuff we've been talking about i'm going
to link them up in the show notes yeah
certainly don't take my word for it and
i'm not a climate scientist i'm not a
scientist
but i think you know it's important that
we all kind of
uh grapple with these issues and i agree
take responsibility for our own
education in the meantime
again i'll just say listen to that
podcast with um
nicholas carter and simon hill plant
proof podcast
check out nicholas carter to check out
dr jonathan foley and others and again
i'll link up those studies
and the tropical forests kind of uh and
aquaculture is in drawdown i believe
expansion of aquaculture yeah yeah
because there's this idea that you can
if you stop taking wild fish stocks and
you and you stop
because there's you can do aquaculture
just like you can do farming in a
regenerative way you can do aquaculture
in a way that's uh
i know not every you know not to be i i
am 90
95 plant-based as an eater but i'm just
saying that one of the solutions to
uh instead of using large cafos and
and people feeding on on red meat and
chicken
which is really bad for the climate is
this idea that if you pump if people ate
more fish and you grew the fish in a way
that's sustainable
then you can draw down carbon that's why
it's in in drawdown
um but the idea for tropical forest 61
gigatons part of that again goes back to
real biodiversity and what biodiversity
does
when you leave a place alone right yeah
cool
all right we ready to move on ready to
move on
you want to get into you want to get
into this you have a hot take on another
netflix doc i do my octopus teacher
my octopus teacher you got to see my
octopus teacher
it's great i love my octopus teacher
this is turning into a documentary film
review podcast yes the last two times
next time we're not gonna i'm not
watching any more documentaries
for at least a month but this is good
because we need you know
these water cooler moments like these
these are movies that we can all see
that are accessible to all of us yes
and it gives us and there i and i love
these movies and
i like talking about them so if there's
another good documentary that comes out
next week
that's coming up on the podcast i'm
gonna get a text
wait my octopus teacher is basically
what we what my friends and i have been
doing for eight years
at point doom
this movie was made for me well i i feel
first of all my friends are still going
out to the reef almost every day and
they're sending me
images and it's it is a little bit
depressing
to not be able to go out but obviously i
have i have bigger things on my plate
and i'm holding
i'm holding a creature in my arms versus
so i should say
sorry to interrupt just to interject
when we talk about swimming around the
reef
the first time i went and did this with
you i'm used to
going out with a group of people and
hammering right like you know we're
swimming like we're
this is a workout and i go out with you
and you you've got a scuba mask
on and i'm like what is happening here
this is not the normal
open water swimming crew that i'm used
to no and then you're just diving to the
bottom
and this is like we're taking our time
and i was like we're looking at
first i'm like what i got to get my swim
in
yeah you might have been finally after
like 30 minutes of this
i was like okay i get it like this is
just something totally different
like for you know forget about your
workout we're here to like smell the
roses
yeah yeah it's very smell the roses we
and i didn't realize that actually at
the time because until
i started going to this uh hit gym and
started doing swim run i didn't realize
how much i wasn't getting in shape with
my swims i used to think that that was
getting me in shape like five times a
week
no like getting fit and it is it
absolutely zone zero
is what it is this is literally zone
zero you cannot get in shape swimming
the way we do
or the way croc craig foster does who is
this um
you know he's a wildlife photographer
that has that that is from south africa
and the idea is that he's he's having a
midlife crisis
basically he's having a emotional
breakdown and he decides to go back to
his family's beach house on the cliffs
of the most amazing coastline
in all of africa and uh and he swims
every day and he meets an octopus
who teaches him the ropes but it's it's
very similar to what we do is we go down
and we swim in the reef and we see the
animals and and it is and so in that way
it touched me and the angle
and he has a gifted photographer like
his own footage that is kind of
beautiful it's unbelievable um so that's
the kind of basis but let's hear the
heart right
it's a beautiful movie and it does such
an elegant job
of creating this connectivity with the
natural world and the mysteries of the
natural world and how much there is for
us to learn
like it's humbling it's like this this
beautiful
mainline injection of humility like we
think we know what's going on and in
truth we don't and there's so much
beauty and majesty and mystery
right in front of us if we would just
slow down
and take the time to pay attention you
know and and that's a big part of what i
got out of it yeah
um and i love it you know and i think
uh i think
well a couple things first of all
where's your hot take
i'm getting to it i'm working up to it i
want to make sure everybody understands
that i love this movie
first what a badass craig foster is to
go in this water without a wetsuit first
of all because that what what is it like
90 degrees celsius so what is that i
mean that's crazy cold
and he's out there every day for like a
really long time this is the seventh
nobody the movie wouldn't be any worse
for wear if he's like putting on a
wetsuit every day
but but he won't he he won't even he's a
purist he's a purist
and he won't take a scuba tank no but he
has he has his freediving fins and
weights right
yep right but he's got to come up for
air and he's diving down pretty
deep so yeah i think it's like 25 feet
you know i think that it doesn't work is
that
part of just his
um trying to be as connected to that
world as possible by not
like kind of putting on any artifice you
know i don't know he doesn't really
describe it but if you if you think
about it like he was emotionally
like damaged he was feeling emotionally
fragile
and so he wanted to feel the ocean i
think he explained it as
um when he was tracking animals in um
botswana right and he was with or was it
burundi or botswana i thought was i
can't remember
but he was with the tribe in africa they
were barefoot and
they were part of the and they were the
best trackers he'd ever seen
and he had been doing this long film
with them and he was so taken by them
and he wanted to be a part of the
environment so i think he was inspired
by those guys those hunters and trackers
right and that's why he went with no
wetsuit my hot take
is that this movie is really a movie
about mental illness
it is this is a guy who clearly
was suffering yeah right and we don't
really know
exactly the cause of his the root of his
suffering and we don't know
exactly what he was going through
because it's only very tangentially
alluded to
they don't spend a lot of time getting
into like the backstory other than to
show him
making that movie you know tracking in
africa but clearly
there's something that he's struggling
with and
he loses himself and his this movie is
about his journey back to wholeness and
the impact of you know this
this ecosystem and in particular this
one octopus has on on healing
him really but i couldn't help but think
like well what is
is it depression maybe it's maybe it's
manic depression because there is a
mania with his obsession
once this clicks in with him yeah where
everything else in his world
gets pushed away and it's just all about
this octopus and he's coming home
and he's putting pictures up on the wall
yeah and it's almost like you know the
trope of the you know the cop who's
hunting the serial killer
and you're like what is going on with
this guy well and
he's got a family he's got a son he's
got a wife at the beginning although we
don't see the wife at the end so i'm not
sure what happens
there you don't think she stuck through
it i i don't know i don't know i don't
know if she did i mean
you know wouldn't if she was still
around wouldn't she have
been part of that conclusion on
something i don't know
maybe she didn't want to be a part of it
i don't know but i'm thinking about
the sun when he's putting up the
pictures on the wall
yeah thinking what's going on with the
sun right now when his dad is like you
know it's becoming obsolete
you know i mean there's an absentee
aspect to it i'm sure
and and that couldn't have been easy for
his family
so while he's being healed i would i
would suspect that
that you know the domestic life was very
challenged by this but it was probably
even more challenged
by him prior to that when i was
suffering even more deeply
he probably got to the point where his
wife's like sure go out how many
five hours today good you should go for
six
but you know what i i see i didn't take
i mean i agree it was a midlife crisis
movie but
um it's mo it's more of a bit more more
than a midwife
a severe crisis and you know he's he's a
very interesting
character clearly very talented with a
camera i'm unbelievable and
and and obsessive but also like an art a
true artist yeah an artist a true artist
like maybe
the pictures he's putting up on the wall
are incredible the collections he makes
it's unbelievable and basically he's
trying to
mimic the the
tracking that he witnessed in africa and
ply that
underwater which is incredible how do
you track an octopus underwater what are
the traces that you're looking for and
like
the forensics of that alone are insane
right it is like
a weird like like csi south africa
you know what i mean yeah the other way
to look at it from the octopus point of
view is
this octopus was being stocked its
entire life
do you think you shake hands with one
human being and you're stalked for the
rest of your life
do you think it was the same octopus
that's are you are you a my octopus just
asking the question you just asked the
tough questions
i think it was i trust craig foster's
obsession
i i hope so i hope so um um but at the
end of the movie
the end of the movie he's not swimming
alone he's got a group of people none of
them are allowed to wear
yeah i'm really glad that it brought he
it brought her you know his son came
back into the picture at the end and you
see this bond between them and how this
process has ultimately brought them
together and they can now have this
shared experience
i hedge a little bit on the family it's
impossible to know through these movies
or any books like what a person's family
life is like
they might just keep it out just to keep
it private but that's kind of part of
the story though yeah
yeah you would want it to be and it is
part of this story his relationship with
his son and it's not really delve
they don't really go into it too much
it's like almost the
a little bit the opposite problem with
the last movie we talked about where
they take on a bunch of issues to the
point where they can't get in depth
in some ways whereas this is so deep
into one place it's very
it doesn't it doesn't kind of encompass
the focus is very narrow
yeah yeah yeah it's like you're not
cutting away to
the sun sharing his perspective on what
his dad's doing
i kind of wanted that but i understand
why you know they
did it the way that they did it and and
look we didn't even talk about what it's
really about which is
he immerses himself in this environment
and by being very patient and showing up
day after day he develops this
connection with this octopus he's
observing it relentlessly
yeah and he ends up learning all about
this incredible creature
which is one of the most intelligent
creatures on earth yeah
in a way that you know even other
scientists you know he's like making
discoveries
like first-time discoveries about
behavior that people didn't even realize
and i think
what you get from that is that
it goes back to humility like we think
we're at the top of the food chain we're
the most intelligent animal well
intelligence comes in many different
forms
we have a certain kind of intelligence
that allows us to be very good at
certain things
but when you see the intelligence of
this creature
you realize like this is unbelievably
smart unbelievable
animal that is so
adept in its environment and so good at
survival
it's amazing like when it collects all
those shells and rolls up into a ball
to like disappear or change his colors
which you might have seen in like
planet before right but when you
actually see it played out and there's
like a whole
methodology to this whole thing and then
how it
gets comfortable around him and swims up
on him and attaches to his chest
and it's beautiful all the way to you
know i keep saying he it's a she
yeah and then the mating and then
the giving birth and very charlotte's
web at the end then
yeah yeah it's beautiful and um you know
one thing
that craig foster makes a really good
point is that like people always ask him
why do you go to the same place every
day and they've asked
us that same thing why are you always
going to the same place wouldn't it be
cooler
wouldn't you learn more if you went
other pla other dive sites and he said
to learn about the wild you got to go
back to the same place every day
and i find that to be so profound it's
like it's like it's very zen buddhist
it's very zen buddhist it's very
localist you know there's a like
argument of it's very zen buddhist in
that wherever you go there you are you
don't have to travel the world to know
the world
right right it would be like going into
your backyard and just staring at the
same ant hill
every day we could all do that
you know wait you have a cool ant hill
in your backyard probably
i wouldn't even know i don't have a
backyard bro but
you might have like a spider web or
something like that
the point being like there's nature
everywhere if you slow down and pay
attention
but there's a wim hof element of being
in cold water so that shocks you
yeah and then just like can we give some
just take a moment to pause at the
breathtaking beauty
and incredible majesty of africa like
africa you don't even
you think of africa like you could think
of it in a million different ways
kinetic cities incredible music uh
like colorful and beautiful cultures and
traditions
um the big five animals all the
incredible
animals in the east africa all the way
the mountain gorillas and then you see
this coastline that's like big sur times
10.
right it's so it's like majestic like
unbelievable yeah i mean those waves
crashing you're like i can't believe
you're going swimming out there yeah
he's a badass it's crazy he didn't get
just
washed up on the rocks yeah he knows
what he's doing so
anyway props to africa i i want to get
out there i want to go i want to go
i want to join the group for a swim yeah
i want to never been to africa
all right my octopus teacher it's on
netflix right
yeah all right on netflix check it out
all right let's take a break and we'll
be back
with a little show and tell and some
listener questions
and we're back back back in action
um all right show and tell so this week
uh a new article came out in the journal
science news study
it was co-authored by my friend marcus
erickson at five gyres
and fi and marcus led a study the the
first
global estimate of amount of plastic
that is actually swirling in the oceans
and at the time it was in 2015 when when
that came out
it was uh 5 trillion tons of plastic
is that when they were saying the the
patch was the size of texas
that's right and the patch is the size
of texas but uh
it doesn't mean there's like big sheets
of plastic swirling around
most of it looks exactly like this this
was collected by marcus
in the north pacific job so explain that
for people that are just listening so we
talked about microplastics before the
idea is the plastic
ends up in the in the waterways and
breaks down to plankton-sized particles
and it gets nibbled on by fish and
that's how it detoxifies the food chain
detoxifies nature
um but these little plastic particles
get they they
get into plastic gets into the water and
there's five oceanic
main oceanic gyres current systems
what's a gyre
it's a gyre is like this swirling
current and it breaks
macro currently it's a giant current
influential current
and the north pacific has one the south
pacific has one north atlantic south
atlantic and there's one in the indian
ocean those are the main gyres
right um i'm not sure about the southern
ocean but those are the main oceanic
gyres that uh
five gyres uh looks at and so the the
plastic get into rivers get into the
ocean and it just travels a lot of it
travels
sometimes it'll beach itself sometimes
it'll just continue to travel
into this gyre it'll just start swirling
and kind of the toilet bowl
situation and it breaks down and so
these are micro plastics
these little jars this is the north
pacific gyre let me see that
this is so it just it looks like like
large grain sand
sort of that's multicolored pebbles yeah
and some of it's really tiny
here's north atlantic gyre this was
collected on the expedition i was on
with five gyres and
uh so exactly it looks different based
on where you know which part of the
ocean you get it from which ocean well
it looks the same
but it's just like there's less of it
and you know that that's the great
pacific garbage patch that was
but those were pulled out of water that
was as blue as you could imagine it
didn't look like anything was in it
looks like perfectly clear and yet
you're pulling that
because you can't see it it just looks
like little flakes these are nurdles
um it came from a hong kong plastic
plant noodles are the base element of
all plastic
it's just a base element that becomes
any plastic
item a bottle so this is what all
plastics
start with like these little tiny little
kernels or nodules that it just looks
like sea salt
yeah like large grain sea salt and like
or grains or ice
mm-hmm and that's what my our when we
talked about the burrito guys on the
podcast the guys that turned the yeah
fishing nets back into nerdles
uh that's what they do anyway so uh i
brought that in because
there's this new study that estimates
there's nine in 2016 they looked at it
19 to 23 million metric tons or 11 of
the plastic weight
waste generated globally entered the
aquatic system so
one out of every 10 items that you're
throwing away that's plastic
ends up in the water and that if we do
nothing
i talked to marcus on the drive here i
spent a little time chatting with him
and he said that if we do nothing at all
um
that number by 2030 will go to be 80
million
metric tons that we throw away so
literally four times what we're
currently seeing
four times he says that he's
uh authoring us another study now an
updated global estimate and he says it's
10 times at least
what they thought in 2015 which was 5
trillion metric tons it's going to be at
least 10x that
in this new study and basically
he said that uh this new study that came
out in science this week
isn't really about the problem so much
as how do you solve the problem
and so there's no magic bullet there's
no there's no magic bullet situation
there's a few things that we can do and
we need to work on all of them
simultaneously
one is moratorium on plastic production
facilities uh
the industry is putting billions of
dollars into building new plastic plants
you've seen reporting on it i'm sure
so that one is a moratorium the other is
bands on single-use plastics things like
bottle bands bag bands all packaging
bands
the eu has all single-use plastic bands
that's in place uh kenya has really
strong
uh rules on that is one thing that
marcus told me and uh
and with the pandemic even myself who i
was really good about no plastic
uh you know i've been going to the
farmer's market and using pre-packaged
plastic
uh bags worth of you know tomatoes or
whatever the fruit might be
uh or food because i don't want a bunch
of
people you know feeling up my produce
and
coveting on it um but and he and i asked
that him about that he said
you know look we gotta we gotta take
care of uh
of you know essential workers we have to
take care of ourselves you have to take
care of human beings
so for now if we're taking a small step
back and using plastic he's not he's not
poo pooing any of that but long term we
need to start making
this change and the number one change
that needs to be made is something
called
extended producer responsibility which
means if you are
procter gamble and you are packaging
something in plastic
you then have to be responsible for
disposal of that thing
as it is now they just dump a bunch of
plastic into the waste system
cities our tax money goes towards uh
trying to get rid of it
right they're absolved of any
responsibility for what happens to it
after that so the proposal is that
it's an end-to-end responsibility if you
produce it then you have to be
on the hook for how it gets recycled or
where it ends up
so then the money goes into you have to
start to
r d figure out ways to create packaging
that can be reused
and us as consumers shouldn't have to
expect like uh
you know a shiny thing necessarily it's
the problem is that even if it's
designed to be reused most people just
throw the [ __ ] out
anyway right so then that that goes in
where the money goes you have to
you have to make inroads to these local
plants there has to be a plan
in place for you to ship that back to
your facility wherever that might be
your distribution machinations are so
insane i mean the title of this science
article is predicted growth in plastic
waste exceeds efforts to mitigate
plastic pollution so it's
it's sort of like the doping situation
like the dopers are always a step ahead
of the detectors right so the plastic
production
is just ahead of our ability to mitigate
it
with these machinations like we have to
go through all of these crazy
you know processes to try to get a
handle on this
can't we just invent something that
disintegrates after a certain amount of
time or you know what i mean like
there has to be some kind of
technological solution
that would um that would render plastic
obsolete like that i feel like that's
the only way
we're gonna get a handle on this because
otherwise it's just gonna it can it's
gonna continue to spiral out of control
because the companies will never wanna
invest money into fixing their own
right and there is you know like i don't
know did you watch and kiss the ground
at the very end like when the credits
are rolling did you watch that part
yeah i watched some of it so rosario
dawson's like on
venice on the board of venice and she's
like interviewing random people
and asking them like you know what are
you doing about the about climate change
and like people
either stare at her blankly or they're
like well i use
i use paper straws you know it's like
that's for a lot of people like that's
the one
thing that they're doing but which is
nice it's not necessarily a greenwashing
thing but it's this idea that
when you do this little thing that's
good
but not really having a major impact it
makes you feel like you're part of the
solution and it prevents you from
actually tackling the real issues here
right
and this issue is so out of control and
so beyond
uh you know the average consumer's
ability to get a grasp on it like yeah
okay i'm not going to use plastic bags
but we've been sharing it
like how hard this is but it's not the
average consumer's responsibility so the
point is producers responsibilities
it's got to be put on it you got to go
upstream
you've got to stop this stuff from
coming into the system
that's the only solution so the only
solution is stop
manufacturing it putting a moratorium
creating laws that eliminate it from
coming into the system because you can't
put it on the person on the boardwalk
you can't put it on us it's got to be
put into the companies
uh themselves how is it that so much of
this stuff
ends up in the water i mean that just
goes what is the chain of custody here
that
i mean it spills out every time you know
look have you ever watched a trash truck
drive down the street
yeah so but but all right so we're we're
talking about you know 20
and then moving towards 80. yeah some of
it is
some of it has been um the weights
collected it spills onto the street it's
it's littered some of it has been we
ship our plastic waste overseas and who
knows what happens and
and and it gets sorted um you know i
don't
i don't exactly know if they've if they
looked at exactly how that happens
they've just
quantified how much does and what is the
impact on
marine life like when this stuff is in
obviously we know like the fish eat it
and it detoxifies the fish
but do you have a grip on kind of feels
like well i mean marcus was
was activated on this issue when he took
students as a grad student he took
students to the
i think it was midway islands to study
albatrosses and he found
uh scores of dead albatross on the beach
yeah and they he cut open he cut them
open they
they bisected them right then because
marcus is a mad scientist and he just
had his kids do that
and their bellies were filled with this
plastic and
um so you know you can't overstate its
impact
on wildlife yeah and um and we've all
seen the images of
these once beautiful pristine tropical
beaches
like whether it's in bali or you know
and they're just littered with
you know so much plastic refuse yeah
it's just
horrific yeah and whales that have
turned up with bellies full of plastic
or especially the lunge feeding whales
right
they're getting it that's happened as
well um so
there is a huge impact on wildlife and
and and in terms of the comp like stuff
that will disintegrate you know
often we we see here in la we might get
a smoothie or
a coffee and something with a plastic
that says compostable
those are only compostable in a very
specific uh
technology that heats it up to a to a
various temperature
and most recycling centers that will
receive that
uh container will not have that yeah
i've heard that
and so it's kind of [ __ ] so it makes
you feel like you're doing the right
thing but
so little of that actually gets properly
composted that's right so you know not
to say don't recycle but the point is
we need to stop the manufacturer you
need to go upstream and we need to stop
it
and um and that's the way we got to do
it yeah yeah it kind of
there is an analogy to the regenerative
soil thing and this idea of
you know how we're addressing climate
change like are we just reducing
like how bad we're making it or are we
actually reversing it
you know what i mean so there's like
okay we gotta slow down this
plastic consumption thing but that's not
actually reversing it or
removing it from our waterways you can't
really remove it you know it's already
out there there's that guy buoyance
buoyancy right oh it's not what's going
on what's the latest with it well they
raised 100 million dollars
and they've deployed this within a
handful of weeks it broke down and then
they
moved it to the hawaiian islands and
they tried to refix it and redeploy it
now it's being
transitioned into like a river cleanups
thing because you know you can't it's
very hard to
put a piece of machinery out in the
middle of the ocean and not have it
break down i mean salt water
corrodes and erodes i mean that's what
it does so uh i don't think it's going
very well for my own
that's a bummer
magic bullet solutions just don't work
really when it comes to this stuff
um and i think it is possible you know
we never would have thought plastic bags
would become illegal and they did so
you know like i think there is there is
a way
you got to put it it's not consumer
based it's producer-based you have to
ask people
to be responsible for their [ __ ] just
like you do your kid
you know like if you if your kid takes
something somewhere
don't just leave it on the ground in a
broader context
i feel like as a culture we've become
less and less
capable of unifying around solutions
that are community oriented you know and
and part of this is government
responsibility but we're so fractured
right now like
can we really come together to solve our
biggest problems like
covid was this amazing opportunity for
us to stop
we're being put in time out let's really
take a hard look at some of these
systems and the impact that they're
having on our planet
and i feel like we're missing that
moment that it's passing us by
without really taking advantage of what
it's being offered like
in the 70s when they realized that
aerosols were
harming the ozone we were able to like
eradicate that
and take care of that right and now you
know
saying you can't like it right stop
making it right same deal like why can't
we just
no more plastic bags right no more of it
like we can
we just don't we don't do it because
then and now we have because and then it
comes and then it becomes politicized
and we argue about it
and that's deeply concerning to me i
think that's the bigger issue is like
can we come together to solve our
well look look here's the deal like we
especially in the podcast community
where like in
in in the kind of area that that you
specialize in and
even joe rogan you have these people
that come on the david goggins of the
world who say
who who are paragons of i took i took
care of my sh
i looked at myself in the mirror i owned
my [ __ ]
i changed my life and i became more
and i've become empowered and we love
that
those are great stories and we consume
those and we and they become they become
our
kind of mentors by proxy that we follow
either on instagram or just we read the
books or we watch the films or whatever
it is
and they become who we we want ourselves
to be a p
we want a piece of that for ourselves
and we don't demand that
of people in the public space of
corporations we don't demand it somehow
somehow we're those people are exempt
you know you
they're not they're not supposed to look
after their own [ __ ] or you look at a
guy like trump
if i lose i didn't lose you know like
the absolute
opposite of someone who owns their [ __ ]
and is
and it has integrity so all we're asking
is
look company no one says don't make
money we're all
i like making money make your money but
look at the at the earth look at the
greater culture look at the you know
have some responsibility to everybody
else
that's all we're asking so can we ask
that of a corporation
it's certainly out of the box i'm not
saying it's easy but i think we should
be able to ask it
and we could ask it once once back in
the day we were asking those questions
back to the broader issues i mean part
of the reason why we love
those stories of transformation is that
it
speaks to our um innate
um uh attraction to this idea of like
rugged individualism
like i can do it right it's up to me and
like and there's something very american
about that
like manifest destiny and it's about
self-interest and the self-made man and
when
we see somebody who accomplishes
something we we love to
kind of celebrate that as an example of
what is a very american
ideal i think it's very it's very u.s
centric in that regard at least the
fervor that we have for that kind of
story is very particular
um and that's at odds
with the commonwealth right like when we
have these
existential crises they require us to
come together and we don't
celebrate the community rising up to
solve the problem
in the way that we celebrate the
individual who's able to like
overcome obstacles himself like can we
apply
that that you know enthusiasm that we
have for those kind of individual
stories to
a common story where we come together as
a people to solve a problem and overcome
an obstacle
i like that new way of storytelling all
right let's do some listener questions
there's a question that kind of gets
into some of this i think
hi rich hi adam my name's tristan i'm
calling you from the unseated
territories of the musqueam
and coast salish people in vancouver bc
i'm a dual citizen of the us and canada
and i've lived in both so i've been
comparing and contrasting the two
countries for some time now
i've been wondering if there's some
cultural root difference
that could explain why our value systems
are manifested in
policy and behavior so differently
almost to the point that americans
appear to champion
freedom but reject responsibility
when canadians generally accept freedom
and responsibility
as two sides to the same point i'm
thinking for example
how as americans we want the right to
bear arms but not the universal
background checks or common sense
restrictions
we want the freedom to run a business
but not so much the responsibility of
dealing with the ways to byproducts of
production
we want to move fast and break things in
the tech world
but we don't want to take responsibility
for how that affects society
we want the right to vote and our
outrage that the thought of foreigners
interfering in our elections
but we interfere with and overthrow
other governments
we want to use a fast lane to pass
slower drivers
but we won't move over for others i'm
wondering
if you think there's something cultural
that is uniquely american
to account for this love the show thank
you very much
um thanks tristan i feel like this could
be a whole college course
like you could spend a semester on this
question
why canadians are better than americans
no not that
sorry but certainly you know to answer
his question is there a cultural
difference a hundred percent there is
like america you know america like
that's what this is about right that's
what you were talking about yeah it's
what we were talking about what is it
what is it about america and the
american sensibility
and um you know our our shared history
that leads to you know those
observations which
i think are astute that that tristan
made and
you know when you trace it back to echo
what we were just talking about like
our culture is premised on this idea of
liberty and baked into that as this
sense of self-sufficiency and manifest
destiny this idea that
your future rests on your shoulders you
know literally
don't tread on me you know like don't
tread on me get out of my business
get out of the way yeah we came here
from england to
escape a certain you know certain
aspects of
of religious repression and taxation and
we wanted to be left alone to do what we
wanted to do
and i think the genetic material of that
has been passed on generation
after generation after generation it's
so
woven into the fabric of our culture and
part of that is what makes us
great you know it's it's what makes us
different it's what makes this
experiment like so compelling and
dynamic but there's also a part of it
that's incredibly
dysfunctional and we're seeing that
dysfunction
metastasize in certain ways right now
it's different right now like we were
talking about
crises used to unite us yeah right
like what happened when we were heading
into world war ii and all the women had
to go into the factories and they
converted
the automotive factories into you know
making airplanes and making munitions
and all these sorts of things or
you know the new deal with fdr where you
know we just marshaled incredible
um reserves to create these programs to
lift people up from the bottom you know
like
all these things there's so many
examples of work over the history
over the history of our country where we
were able to
you know unite in times of strain to
solve
our shared problems for the common good
and now the crises that used to unite us
seem to divide us they become partisan
they become acrimonious they become
feeding grounds for
you know political talking points and
arrows slung
and social media plays a big part on
this by
really tapping into people's fears by
activating their
subconscious in a in a way that
weaponizes ideas and pits us
against ourselves um and i think you
know
another aspect of it is this idea that a
very american idea of zero-sum game
right like
baked into don't tread on me is like
this is mine
yours is there you can't have what's
mine
and if you're winning then i'm losing
and i think we have a leader at the
moment who you know
exemplifies this idea like nobody else
can win
except him there are no you know there
are there
there are winners and there are losers
and we you know the idea that we can all
win together
is not part of that mentality this
zero-sum sensibility
and that my responsibility only extends
to myself
my needs and that of my family alone
meanwhile as we
modernize and we specialize we've become
more and more alienated from each other
we've lost
you know our connection with our
neighbors we've
experienced this denigration this demise
of community as we
move towards this cul-de-sac culture
where we lock ourselves in our cars and
our homes there's an isolationism
that that is at play here that
i think you can layer on top of this
sense this false sense of american
sort of superiority yeah and entitlement
like
yeah like how dare anybody you know mess
with our elections while we're doing who
knows what
in the third world but that's fine
because we're america right
right this idea of american
exceptionalism
and that's starting to fracture
you know i think we're seeing the look
it's like
there is this unmistakable sense that
like we're like rome
in the final days before the collapse
like these systems don't last forever no
and our system is flawed highly flawed
um so and and the
the way that they were put the systems
were put in place
also was was kind of pro obviously
flawed and problematic and evil in
certain ways and who was treated
with fairly by the law and who still is
right um
but you know in terms of just going to
the core of the question of canada
versus america what makes
it different and i don't i've never
lived in canada so it would be hard for
me to know but
um a few things kind of stand out uh two
of them are
our kind of policy uh and one is more
media but
i you know first of all we just had this
big
supreme court decision when obama was
still in office that made corporations
individuals so i don't think many
countries in the world treat
businesses as individuals they don't
give the same rights to corporations
that they're supposed to give to
individuals
it's crazy corporations are not
individuals they're businesses and they
should be held to a different standard
um canada to my knowledge does not treat
businesses that way
they they they're it's the same thing
with gavin newsom and what happened with
homeowners and trying to get them to
throw their trash out
uh canada gets corporations to throw
their trash out a little bit better than
we do
i mean i think manifest destiny existed
there too i think um
you know first nations as they're called
in
in um canada indigenous people were
treated very poorly and were
eradicated there too so that happened
but in terms of legal uh
legally what's been going on
corporations have more to answer for
than they do in this country they also
have a parliamentary government
um which means that if you win a
government if you win
the prime minister is elected through
their parties the parties are elected
and the leader of the party becomes the
prime minister as far as i know
and uh if you win in a parliamentary
um process if you win by a narrow margin
you are then tasked with creating a
coalition government with people who are
maybe your political opponents and
getting enough people in place to
actually support your government
that means that coalition building is is
baked into the process
that's the same process england has the
same process australia has
we don't have that process i'm not
arguing that it's a better process but
there is a coalition building a communal
uh you know having to see each other eye
to eye and meet
in the middle is it it's baked into the
way they create their laws in canada
we don't have that here it's winner take
all here um you know holding hostage by
the power of the senate or whatever it
might be yeah it's supposed to be
you're supposed to come correct and and
meet and compromise but not
but that's not been happening lately um
no i mean first of all
we're not a democracy we're a democratic
republic there's a difference um
i don't think we talk enough about that
like the republic aspect of how our
government is structured but what we've
seen
in the last several decades is this
explosion in executive powers like this
expansion
of the executive branch that i think
exceeds
the you know what the forefathers would
have ever predicted they're supposed to
be
a very finely tuned balance between the
three
um the the three branches of government
and now it's just all about the
executive and it's all about the
president so i think the president has
too much power meanwhile
with the uh rights that have been vested
in corporations
matched by the way that we structure
campaign finance we've created a
situation with in which lobbyists
actually hold the most power they're
making all the money
and they're the ones who are dictating
policy at the highest level
by getting politicians to do the bidding
of these corporations which are treated
as individuals
and thus we create a system in which
the rights of these corporations are
paramount to the rights of citizens and
that's led us to this place where
we are unable to care for our commons
because
our priority is making sure that
business is growing
and that business is thriving and
campaign finance laws are different in
canada and you can see that and i think
there was a michael moore documentary
was it bowling for columbine where he
like
crosses the border and like starts
opening canadians doors and their doors
are always unlocked
and he looked at the media and there
wasn't like they didn't have cops and no
one was afraid of getting robbed and
they didn't have guns
and their news media actually wasn't all
about
fear first it wasn't headline grabby it
was kind of boring
and uh and and so all of those things i
think was that bowling for
i forget remember yeah but yeah all
right
we answered that question let's move on
thank you
thanks chris thank you tristan all right
hey rich and adam
my name is heidi and i am in the bay
area
um my question or sort of
um conversation that i'd like to open up
is about training and social
responsibility
um so i train with a large triathlon
team
in the bay area i've known the people
now for
nine years plus um and over the years
they've helped me go from 5ks
to multiple iron math niches but more
importantly they're my second family
um in the beginning the pandemic we did
socially distant
workouts and then we just quickly
transitioned when everything was
um you know hell in a handbasket
so we would actually just post virtually
um and in may a lot of my team decided
to
train in person together just keeping
six feet apart but that's really tricky
right with the wind and everything and
i made the decision not to attend
gatherings i noticed through strava
photos people weren't wearing the mask
they're hugging
um my question is i've known these
people for
many years as i mentioned deep
relationships and i
struggle now with reconciling
that and needing that social network um
with disregard for other people and um
it just doesn't seem respectful to me to
be out there with no masks now and
putting my
athletic pursuits number one um
it's for me it feels more selfish so i
know this seems like a judgmental
question all right thank you heidi for
your question
this one's tricky uh and i think
it's applicable more broadly than her
specific question yeah she's talking
about her
triathlon training group but this could
be yeah but we all deal with this yeah
it's like
how are we interacting with our friends
and our peer group
or is it cool to go out and running that
kind of right yeah right and whether
it's
meeting at a restaurant or going out
running or recycling or whatever it is i
you know i think there's there's a
relatable aspect of this question that
extends beyond her specific
circumstances but you know i think it's
i think it's tough and ultimately
all i can say is that you got to do
what's right for you
and you got to stay out of the business
of what other people are doing
and i think you said in your question
this seems judgmental but you're not
being judgmental but i would i would i
would suggest that
perhaps your judgment runs a little bit
deeper than you might be aware because i
feel like you are judging everybody else
or at least this particular group and i
don't think that that judgment
is is serving you or them ultimately you
only have control
over your actions and your reactions not
what anyone else is doing and i
understand that
that peer group that social connection
with that community is important to you
but if your personal safety and
social distancing exceeds that need or
that desire for
your social outlet then that has to
dictate
how you behave right it's tough when
you're talking about training outdoors
you know
and and i think part of what makes this
complicated is
there's a lot of confusion and
uncertainty about
the disease how it's transmitted is it
safe to be outside it's like oh we all
wear masks but then you're
you know i'm walking down main street in
santa monica and there's restaurants and
everyone's sitting outside and they're
not wearing masks and i'm walking right
by them while i'm wearing masks so it's
like it's
it's so it's okay to not wear a mask
when you're sitting down at a table but
not when you're walking like right
it's weird and so i don't you know it's
like how do you make sense
of any of this you don't you can't and
you don't
right so that's why it all goes back to
doing what feels right for you
and and and and also
not putting other people in harm's way
as a result of your behavior i think is
important as well so yeah so do know
first do no harm
and then i would say you know look i
deal with this as well like i like to
train
alone so being with a peer group isn't
as important as it feels like it is to
you
with respect to the training but i do
think when you're outside
and the wind's blowing and you're
somewhat distant from another individual
the chances that you're going to
contract the disease are are pretty
limited and that doesn't mean that you
shouldn't
you know maintain a safe distance and
you know
kind of watch your p's and q's but
that scenario is very different than
going to a bar where the music's loud
and people are yelling and they're
standing right next to each other
and you know the air is not well
circulated like those are
night and day situations although i have
been out riding my bike
by myself but i'll ride up behind
somebody and they're like i don't know
10 meters ahead of me
but when you're riding a bike like you
generate a lot of phlegm you know right
you're doing the snot rockets and like
you're and it's like am i just
even though i'm 10 meters behind if
you're going 15 20 miles an hour
is that just going right into my nose my
rockets are cool right now
when you're riding your bike like your
nose starts to run yeah you got to do
something with that
yeah i mean and a lot of that ends up in
the air like that is that not
the aerosolized droplets that we're
hearing about so
that's not like droplets is this like
worse than me being
you know it's a good question and i
don't know the answer to that
you know what i mean so all i can tell
you is
that um is that uh
you know you should continue to train
but maybe not do it with this group
if you want to you know find a way to do
it with one other person
and you can that way you can kind of
bubble up regulate
the social distancing a little bit more
practically that might be good
uh but i think the broader thing that i
want to express
is is is not getting caught up in what
other people are doing or not doing
because
that's going to make you crazy but it is
hard to do that when
when there is this you see pictures of
people hugging
it's like well yeah on facebook or
whatever you know you know your buddy
you you work at a job and you can't see
your colleagues anymore and then you see
they're going to a bar and you're at
home
trying to do the right thing or whatever
it's right
some people are more committed to
bubbling than others i believe me with
with a newborn and then before that
pregnant wife we were super careful
um and you know i think all you can do
is
have a mask on you so if you're biking
or or running
um we even put them in our wetsuits and
put them on for walking back after
swimming just have it with you and if
you're coming up close on someone put it
up and if not
run free without the mask i think that's
fine that's what i do yeah
um but uh kudos heidi for 5k to not
going from a 5k
to multiple iron man yeah yeah
absolutely amazing
absolutely so all right cool thanks all
right we'll do one more
all right cool let's go to toronto hello
adams and rich
my name is adam i'm 29 years old and
live in toronto canada
i am a big fan of the podcast risks have
been a huge inspiration in my life
i have been eating whole food plant
taste for three years now
recently i started to train and i
aspired to one day
complete an ironman competition as you
did
i have also cured my chronic migraines
since i have changed my diet to whole
foods plantations
my question is how do you inspire
extended family members and friends
to transition to a plant-based diet this
concerns me
especially when i see the health issues
they are experiencing
in addition to the impact that food
choices have on the environments and
animals
uh thank you adam this question
isn't that different from heidi's
question
because an aspect of it has to do
with trying to convince people to do
what you're doing
mm-hmm you know what i mean and control
behavior yeah trying to control the
behavior of others
or being in judgment of others behavior
um
and i get it like i understand the
predicament that you're in you've made
this lifestyle change you had this
amazing
um turn around you've cleared your
migraines
uh and and that's to be celebrated and
amazing and
i think what happens when you're when
you when you have an experience like
that
you then want to be a cheerleader you
want to chant you're like
why isn't everybody doing this like i
need to tell people you want to wave
yeah and and then you quickly run up
into some brick walls because
people don't want to hear it they don't
want your flag
they don't want your flag man go on
reddit
yeah go tell people on 4chan about it
right
and family members can be particularly
tricky yeah right and i can just tell
you yeah i can just tell you
from personal experience like i've been
plant-based for
for 14 years at this point we've got all
these cookbooks so i've got this podcast
like my whole
thing is about advocating absolutely do
you think this has
impacted my family in terms of their
choices around food
no if you think so you would be sorely
mistaken
about that you've influenced a lot of
people but not the ones that love you
right
and that's because sometimes the ones
that love you are the hardest one
because they know you too well right so
if you want to be an advocate that's
great but your audience
might have to extend beyond the people
that you care most about and that's just
the way it goes
my whole way of carrying myself with
this
is to just be a lighthouse i'm not in
the business
of taking other people's inventory and
this is something i learned in recovery
right clean your own house man
make sure your house is clean don't
worry about what's going on
in everybody else's house clean your own
house
don't take inventory of other people's
behavior which is another way of saying
don't be in judgment of other people
three years ago
you weren't eating plant-based if
somebody had come up to you then
and browbeat you about your dietary
dietary choices how would you receive
that
yeah you're probably not so good right
no so be a lighthouse and by that i mean
stand in your power you know be an
example of this
lifestyle live well like be awesome
and in doing that you become a center of
gravity
that puts out this tractor beam that
attracts people
who are vibrating on your wavelink to
you and those are the people who are
going to be receptive to what you have
to say because they're going to petition
you
they're going to come up to you and say
hey you look great like you look
different what are you doing
right will you tell me about that that's
your audience those are the people who
want a little piece of what you have to
offer but trying to roll up on people
who haven't expressed you know that kind
of
sentiment or aren't demonstrating to you
that they're open
about it is generally a losing
proposition
and it becomes off-putting like
basically you're creating the opposite
of what you're trying to do
so also i mean i think that that's so
interesting you said it i was thinking
that is that
what makes you so good at talking about
these issues is that
the recovery background has like put you
in the perfect position to
be not ever caring what somebody else is
eating like that's just
not on your program it's not my job
to be in judgment of what other people
are doing and it's not my job
right yeah because yeah and that's
something you like i learned
early and often yeah in the rooms and i
try to carry that into
the way that i speak about these other
things what's funny is when you get
sober
and i talk about this with my buddies
you get sober and then you're like
you think everybody quit drinking and
doing drugs just like you did
you know and then like every
occasionally you find yourself in a
situation like at a bar or a party and
you're like people are partying and
you're like people still do this
like what is going on you know i thought
we all quit
yeah isn't that the deal we made this is
over right so
that's not dissimilar from when you've
had a lifestyle change that has had such
a positive impact on you and then you're
like i can't believe people are
still doing x y or z like didn't we all
get over that
especially people you know because just
the same way that they
that family knows who you were before
you changed
you know all their dirty little secrets
and know how their eating effect
may affect their their physical issues
it is a it is fraught um but yeah just
the fact that you
um have that background to fall on god
that helps in so many ways it's so
interesting how
the the crosses that we bear and the
things that we overcome you can just
call back
on in so many different fronts in your
life i find that so cool
i mean one thing you can do and i would
say this to adam
it's not like you just completely opt
out of caring about your friends and
your family you can say
like hey you know like this is what's
going on with me
but just lowball it just be like you
know i'm i started eating plants and
like my migraines went away
it's it's about your attachment to the
impact of that like it's about your
relationship to the results
so you can be like hey if you're if
you're ever interested like i'm happy to
talk to you about it or here's a book
that i read i thought it was pretty cool
just as long as you're not walking
around with an expectation that that
book is going to get read
or whatever you're saying is going to
land with that person yeah so you can
make yourself
available if and when that person
shows you know some inclination or
interest in what you have to say
just don't be attached to it because
it's your you're the one who's gonna
suffer
yeah if you bring a vegan lasagna to the
family potluck and nobody eats it
don't throw it on the ground no maybe
just make a better vegan lasagna exactly
like that's the thing julie does she'll
just make something that's so good
and people are like whoa it's not even
like vegan
you don't even have to say it's vegan or
it's not vegan you just make it awesome
and they eat it yeah you know
that's the whole philosophy back to
ryland at the beginning like they have a
restaurant
in addition to cafe gratitude they have
a restaurant called gracias madre
in west hollywood restaurant yeah man i
love that restaurant
it's incredible it's a beautiful
restaurant phenomenal the food is insane
yes not once
nowhere on the menu not on the signage
nowhere does it say
this is a plant-based restaurant or a
vegan restaurant and
i would suspect a lot of people go and
eat there and have no idea i would think
yeah yeah
it's just great and you go there because
the food's awesome yeah and that's the
way that you win
and the vibe is awesome it's a great
place yeah yeah do we answer the
question i'm hungry now
we answered it let's end it let's wrap
it let's land this plane
somebody sent me a comment they said you
should make a t-shirt that's it that
says let's land this plane
so i always say do you ever feel like we
landed it we're on fumes and it's just
like coming in bumpy
all the time all the time at this time
though
last week we stuck the landing we stuck
it that was like
a gymnast on her floor routine yeah it
was perfectly executed
exactly that might have been our our
peak podcast that's it it's all downhill
from here
wait is this my last day here no you're
fired
america are we done
i think we're done all right cool thank
you all right this was good
i always enjoyed it it's fun it was fun
man yeah i had a good time i hope
everyone else enjoyed it as well
yeah um you can follow me on the socials
at rich roll you can follow adam on the
socials at adam skolnik
leave us a message if you want your
question read 424-235-4626
you can also drop one in the facebook
group it's just easier if you leave a
message though then we can
we're getting this better yeah hit that
subscribe button on youtube
apple and spotify we're gonna have some
copious show notes for this episode
because we talked about all this
research with respect to the movie and
all of that so please
um check that out and you can dive
deeper into
the science yeah and all for all the
listeners that uh
sent you know messages on instagram
after the the maya gibberish story kind
of finally came out this week
thank you so much like everyone's like
what happened yeah it came out late it
was held for a week because of the
floods
and they didn't want to have like a big
wave story right people were
you know they felt it was insensitive so
they held it in a week but the timing
just
you never know how the story blew up it
blew up in the timing and
thank you for the listeners who read it
and reach out there's a great article
thanks and it traveled it was i think i
sent a screen grab it was like trending
on twitter
a lot of people were creating it yeah
well everybody likes a video of a big
wave surfer
yeah and a badass woman that's right
yeah
so we should get her on the podcast
absolutely yeah yeah should be cool
totally um awesome so we'll be back in
two more weeks with another one of these
i'll be here until then appreciate you
guys
love you see you back here uh in a
couple days
another awesome episode peace
this is bbc radio 1.
namaste
[Music]
you